Greg Jarrett former U.S attorney Brett
Tolman is with us Greg start with you
all right there's there's a lot to go
over in terms of of what to absorb this
week what we expect next week that we
will hear on Monday from Devin Archer I
assume that it'll be pretty Blockbuster
uh James Comer told me that they're
going to try and get this deposition out
at least the transcript as quickly as
possible hopefully we know by Monday
night when we come back on the air
yeah Devin Archer May blow the whistle I
mean this is a guy who knows where the
bodies are buried in the Biden family
and the barisma scam is a prime example
there's an email where a top barisma
executive Sean demands that Biden uses
influence to close down a criminal
investigation of the company so what
does Hunter do he flies off to Dubai he
meets with the CEO zalesky who demands
that he get his dad the vice president
on the telephone he did and thereafter
Joe Biden travels to Ukraine and he
makes his Infamous extortion demand that
the prosecutor be fired or the U.S will
withhold a billion in financial aid and
within hours of course Victor shoking
was canned so mission accomplished is
that a crime of course it is quid pro
quo violation of the Foreign Corrupt
Practices Act you're using your public
office for self-enrichment and the FBI's
10 23 form is evidence of bribery
zoloshevsky told the confidential in
form of the bidens coercedent into
shelling out an additional 10 million
for the shoken firing 5 for 105 for the
big guy and if the money was funneled
through shell companies to hide the
source that's money laundering so you
know there's is it any wonder that the
doj and the FBI had to shut down the
hunter Biden case to protect Joe Biden
all right Brett let me let me go to you
you know what the judge discovered this
week is interesting to me and I and it
it dovetails into all of this here
because what the prosecution and the
defense had agreed on there's no doubt
there was full agreement to this
paragraph that they stuck in the in the
gun charge section of this plea
agreement the United States agrees not
to criminally prosecute Hunter Biden for
any federal crimes related to the case
uh the deal reads but it only left open
the possibility of prosecution for any
future conduct they were trying to put
this entire issue to rest as it relates
to Hunter Biden now I argue that the
main reason is is to protect Joe Biden
because now we went from Joe Biden
saying I never discussed any foreign
business deals of Hunter too I've never
been in business with Hunter then the
details as as Greg pointed out in the
1023 form then the IRS whistleblowers
all all this new information
cascading down on the the entire web of
lives that they were weaving here uh the
timing could not be worse for them this
judge has got to stand firm on this
Sean thanks for having me on it's very
nuanced unless you've been in the
Department of Justice you've worked as a
federal prosecutor let me tell you let
me break this down for you what they did
what doj did here and why it is a a
racket to protect Joe Biden so when you
file a when you file a plea agreement
that plea agreement by by the U.S
attorney's manual and the and the
Department of Justice policy is required
to list all components of the deal they
didn't do that instead they put the most
important part of the deal the secret
part of the deal they put that in a
separate document it's a diversion
agreement that agreement doesn't have to
be revealed to the public it can remain
confidential the judge just merely asked
a few modest normal questions and and a
landmine occurred in this hearing and
the judge then started to get very
uncomfortable with what was going on so
she asked directly the and you look at
the transcript it's stunning Sean the
judge asked the the U.S attorney's
Office asked the doj prosecutor
have you ever seen an instance in which
we have you have the Department of
Justice has given immunity for crimes
unrelated to what they are pleading
guilty to and this prosecutor said no I
have not and from there it unraveled
they had to admit however that there was
an open investigation because they have
previously told Congress that there's an
open investigation why did they do that
because they want to be able to keep all
of that information away from Congress
arguing that they don't have to turn it
over under foia so all of this was
supposed to be a nice packaged secret
deal where two sides were actually on
the same side trying to protect Joe
Biden Craig and Brett thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else